you grow grew up knowing blues icon
legend BB King is that right I did yeah
you knew him I mean when you were a baby
how did this yeah well my aunt was uh
his publicist for for a little while I
didn't know yeah yeah yeah yeah when I
was a kid and she did for like Wolfman
Jack and Phyllis Diller and share a few
other people and and I did I met him
when I was uh when I was two years old
Wow the first time BB King I mean this
is the guy and and and I saw him all
throughout my my childhood and and when
I was 14 years old that he said listen
ona I'm gonna take Walton on the on the
road with me which is a big deal it's my
14th birthday and and so he said I
wanted to get on the bus in Birmingham
and then I'm gonna take you to Atlanta
and and and it was a really really big
deal and I got to hang out with a band
and I knew the band kind of at that
point because I'd been seeing them for
years
yeah and and we got into this we got
back we got to Atlanta we went in this
hotel room used to come up here you know
come and let's sit and let's talk and
that's mr. BB king you gonna say yes
right so I go in man this is him this
weekend I'm sitting there and and he
said he gives me $100 $100 and he says
now I want you to go see the world and I
looked at him and I said but she only
gave me $100 but no we he probably
thought it was like 1938 yeah yeah right
but he was a friend up until the the day
that he died and I saw him when I moved
to Los Angeles 27 years ago right and I
saw him I don't know probably 15 or 6
whenever he would come into town I'm
told that you got onstage and performed
with him once
do you play guitar what you know I play
guitar for myself yeah one else wants to
hear me play guitar but but I was a
clogger
here man the club know I'm a clowder
yeah mom what do you mean you're a
clogger well I mean you know I mean I
you know I you dance
it's like no it's like this right I mean
so it's just it's a shuffle step shuffle
step boom boom like it's like that and
so I I did well I don't know man that's
pretty good I saw what you did earlier
yeah it's a little like river dancing
but their prey but I lean on clogs and
you would clomp around in clogs and
blues legend show well I was actually he
he sponsored these prison shows at the
Atlanta Fulton County prison and and so
he had my mom who got me into clogging
yeah he had us perform you know for him
like I don't know I did it two or three
times it did you fog alone or you know
it's with with my with my mother and he
wasn't there were you the clog in
Goggins like a little point when I took
because I like to travel and and I took
I back when blogging I suppose was like
in fashion I did this for my friends and
so then they called me the clogging
blogging Goggin yeah yeah your life is
pretty much over
you